[Musique]
le temps sera agréable sur l'ensemble du
département
c'était en novembre 2012 à 25 ans lydie
jolivet réaliser son rêve présenter la
météo à la télévision
merci à vous bien évidemment de m'avoir
regardez là depuis un grand bonheur est
arrivé dans la vie de l'île
liddy a aujourd'hui 30 ans et elle vit à
stella dans les hauts de saint leu avec
son compagnon damien et leur petite
fille 1000 lits dix souffre de la
maladie de friedreich une maladie
génétique rare qui provoque des pertes
d'équilibré et des problèmes de
coordination au niveau des mouvements
mais également au niveau de la parole
c'est génétique dégénérative
donc j'ai ça depuis la naissance mais
c'est apparu au moment de l'adolescence
par l'âge de 17 18 ans donc j'ai eu le
temps de demi maginez
on est en plein de jolies pourtant le
talon très dynamique très sportive et
puis en fait rien tout ça ma vie cinq
ans après le diagnostic
lydie est arrivée à la réunion et malgré
les difficultés
elle a toujours voulu être indépendante
pouvoir se déplacer seule a les seins
voiture elle a passé le permis de
conduire et c'est au volant d'une
voiture spécialement équipée
quelle part travailler ma main droite va
me servir pour freiner et pour mettre
mes clignotement
trois arrivées à destination
lydie rejoint la boutique d'optique où
elle est employée à temps partiel à 80 %
à la sortie de saint leu elle a même eu
une promotion
aujourd'hui elle est la responsable
[Musique]
je suis ravi qu'on met tait quand il
fait confiance c'est vrai que bon il
faut banny qui a pas beaucoup d'équipés
y en a car elle met
je pense avoir fait mes potes on s'en
fout carnet en trouver
des moyens de
de pas bien cela est ce que le regard
des clients est parfois difficile non
lorsque le client va vider
voyons ce regard qu'il un petit peu
surpris tout bon tu réagis dans ce cas
là avec le sourire je sais de pas
montrés que
ça me laissait parfois et s'il ya
quelque chose que tu es le passé le mot
handicapés s'il ya quelque chose que
j'aime pas et je vous interdit de dire
que nous sommes handicapés
nous sommes dans ce café mais autrement
capables de briser cet après midi liddy
a rendez vous avec sa kinésithérapeute
ça fait un moment qu'elle ne se sent
plus vu car depuis qu'elle a accouché
liddy a fait une pause au niveau des
soins
[Musique]
et justement ce soir mon conseil c'est
déficit
l'intérêt
l'idée a de plus en plus de mal à
marcher seule sa maladie et
dégénératives
elle sait très bien que les choses
risquent d'empirer dans les prochaines
années mais elle ne veut pas y penser
les nuits
l'évolution de la maladie c'est une
question angoissante oui oui c'est pas
angoissante mais stressante
donc je préfère pas savoir
voilà
et
en mer et tu ne sais pas non
pa je me doute le risque c'est
évidemment de se retrouver en chaise
roulante parce que
la recherche a
pas suffisamment vite or justement
ces deux ne devienne pas réalité c'est
ça l'espoir c'est ça laisse pas là la
recherche soit rattrapé que oui je vais
guérir avant d'être bloqué à 6
j'active
et en attendant lydie croque la vie
aquabiking randonnée vélo et bientôt
parachutisme rien ne lui fait peur quand
nous la retrouvons chez elle elle nous
propose de feuilleter les albums photos
d incroyable voyage qu'elle a fait ces
dernières années
je pense que je suis en permanence en
combos possibles
forcément ce défi comme les relever on
est en lève mais toutefois damien il
trouve qu'elle exagère tito que tu veux
disons que quand le volcan fait est que
le cratère française était selon
l'organisation les voyages avant les
défis tête de livre bank deux des fils
de deux cdd puis c'est compliqué mais
sur sa red bull
parce que j'ai un char est le plus fort
du monde qui tient deux bien son rôle de
papa et qui est très présent et qui
m'aide beaucoup
mais c'est le mien et ça c'était le
premier passage avec un problème c'est
d'elle parce que les gens dans la rue
jusqu'à l'année dernière et que vous est
inconnu quand j'avais ce qui est
formidable à la réunion c'est quelqu'un
de tolérant
ici c'est un dois me demander
dix fois par jour si jay z et çà çà çà
çà impressionner sa patrie et depuis la
naissance de la petite mila la vie de
l'idi a encore pris une autre dimension
ce n'est pas toujours facile mais pour
lydie il n'y a rien d'impossible
il n'y a rien de compliqué at-elle
l'habitude de dire c'est tout dans la
tête